persistence not politics that's the
focus of tonight's angle now it can get
really depressing I know it watching and
reading all the coronavirus coverage I
mean I'm one of them it gets depressing
after a while well the numbers around
the world are still increasing 240,000
people infected over ninety eight
hundred dead the elderly are living in
fear families are wondering why the heck
their lives are ever gonna be normal
again
and without their school routines take
it from me I'm living with this many
children or anxious parents just a
little stressed a restaurant tour and
neighbor a dear dear man a friend of
mine had to let go 300 employees today
some of these folks have been with him
for twenty years he was heartbroken it
just seems like a never-ending stream of
bad news but but there are important
signs of hope light you could see it
look closely it's at the end of the
tunnel companies in the United States
and elsewhere are stepping up and
retooling their operations to turn out
medical supplies hand sanitizers
ventilators and more help for all of us
to fight this coronavirus more people
and this is really good are getting
tested every day between March 2nd and
March 14th ten point four million lab
tests were put into the healthcare
system 45,000 people have been tested
through the CDC membrane was complaining
about the CDC with 45,000 63,000 have
already been tested by commercial labs
20,000 tests already resolved hundreds
of thousands more are coming in the next
week look the president wanted results
he's impatient for results and he got
them and he got them when Secretary of
Health and Human Services Alex a czar
pushed for the private sector to take
this up along with a massive
deregulatory push we're very effectively
transitioning to large-scale testing by
leveraging all components
American healthcare system the FDA has
made available a number of options for
supplies different swabs different
reagents we are standing on 47 sites in
12 states and here's some other
promising news about Kovan nineteen's
mortality rate now check this out using
a slew of public and previously
published information a group of
researchers estimated the probability of
dying after developing symptoms of Cova
19 in Wuhan was 1.4 percent now that's
it's still like I'm not great we don't
want anyone to die but that's at least
50% lower as a mortality rate than has
been previously reported in many
different outlets now let's hope that
number holds overtime and especially as
more people are tested worldwide even
those who are asymptomatic but perhaps
the best news of all is about a drug I
brought to your attention on Monday
night now at first it kind of seemed to
me and I'm a little skeptical although
it seemed too good to be true but the
results in France in China and Beyond
have been nothing short of impressive
what if there's already a cheap and
widely available medication that's on
the market to treat the virus well
according to a new study there is such a
drug it's called chloroquine all of
these different antivirals have been
shown fairly promising and some of the
early trials some of them in vitro are
those the types of antivirals for the
treatment not the vaccine that you all
are looking at right yeah we have to be
careful Laurie that we don't assume
something works based on an anecdotal
report that's not controlled and I refer
specifically to hydroxychloroquine Laura
you've been great about calling
attention to this drug President Trump
is absolutely adamant that we leave no
stone unturned and bringing therapies
cures vaccines to the American people
well the angles persistence paid off
because today President Trump made this
announcement a drug called chloroquine
and some people would add to it hydroxy
hydroxychloroquine it is known as a
malaria drug and it's been around for a
long time and it's very powerful it's
shown very encouraging very very
encouraging early results and we're
going to be able to make that drug
available almost immediately now after
this happened the drug company Bayer
donated 3 million of the pills of this
particular drug to the Trump
administration now although the FDA
still has not approved the drug for use
as a treatment for Cova 19 doctors here
can still prescribe it that's a drug
that the president has directed us to
take a closer look at as to whether an
expanded use approach to that could be
done to actually see if that benefits
patients and again we want to do that in
the setting of a clinical trial a large
pragmatic clinical trial to actually
gather that information and answer the
question that needs to be answered and
asked and answered well I have a feeling
and given the fact that most the country
is locked down right now that a
controlled study of I don't know 2,000
patients could be organized pretty
quickly given what's at stake here I'll
happily volunteer if you're looking for
volunteers ok I'll volunteer
the FDA FDA needs to hop onto this
pronto it looks like they are that's
great news
now seeing the president snap his team
into action
and in the process harnessing the full
power of the government all the
government the private sector and our
citizens who are doing great acts of
selflessness during this entire crisis
it gives all of us hope in this really
difficult time as we've done with polio
and the measles and so much else we'll
find the answers we need we've beaten
diseases in the past and we'll do it
again and that's the angle